[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily another minnesota
police officer facing
criminal charges for the death of an
unarmed man
officer kim potter booked into jail on
second-degree
manslaughter charges for fatally
shooting duante wright
plus the defense of derek chovin goes
into its second day
with a former medical examiner saying
chauvin did not kill
george floyd i would fall back to
undetermined
and arrest made in the disappearance of
a california college student
more than two decades ago the tips that
led to charges against kristin smart's
former classmate i'm confident that we
have
enough of a case to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
law and crime date covering court cases
from
coast to coast
and welcome to long time daily i'm brian
ross in our studios in new york with
brian buckmeyer on assignment in
minneapolis for the trial of derek
shoven and with us as always our
colleague terry austin
big news out of minnesota with a police
officer charged with second-degree
manslaughter for the shooting death of a
young man
but first to our coverage of the derrick
chauvin trial and brian buckmeyer is
here with the latest on the case being
made
by the defense brian
yeah brian ross so eric nelson asked as
any defense attorney would
for what's called a directed verdict
basically saying that in the light most
favorable to the prosecution
they haven't made out the elements or
the charges that are being faced by
derek chovin
now eric nelson pointed out to the fact
that two of the witnesses for use of
force given the example of
lieutenant zimmerman and chief aerodondo
their testimony was similar but it
seemed to contradict that
of the other witness professor stalton
in terms of his use of force
and when and where that use of force was
inappropriate the judge ultimately
decided that the status or the
um level by which the defense was asking
it should be dismissed
beyond a reasonable doubt was
inappropriate that the standard is
in the light most favorable to the
prosecution and that the the defense
was incorrect in stating that the jury
can kind of pick and choose what
information they want
to reach that ultimate conclusion and so
the judge deny that motion
and allow the jury to make a decision
for guilt or innocence brian
okay thanks brian maurice hall the
suspected drug dealer who was with
george floyd the night he died
will not testify law and crimes anjanet
levy is here to explain why
hall thinks he could face charges
anjanette
brian maurice hall was arrested during
jury selection on
unrelated charges he may not he is not
going to testify in the shove and trial
he won't be required to do so but his
legal troubles
could be just beginning i'm right here
all right i appreciate that man the
video doesn't lie
maurice hall was clearly in cup foods
with george floyd last may and then in
the suv
hall's lawyer says that is why he can't
answer questions put forward by derrick
chauvin's defense
why would you not answer those i'm
fearful of criminal charges going
forward
i have open charges that's not settled
yet
of my personal stuff chauvin's defense
has suggested hall caused floyd's death
by giving drugs that led to an overdose
hall's lawyer believes his testimony
could lead to him facing charges
including drug possession mr hall cannot
put himself
in that car with mr floyd again this was
a car that was searched twice and drugs
were recovered
twice let's say mr shovin is then
acquitted
he has now given the state on a silver
platter testimony to use against him
in a third degree murder charge if they
decide to bring it hennepin county's
medical examiner dr
andrew baker ruled floyd's death a
homicide due to being restrained by law
enforcement
but he also called floyd's death
multifactorial
stating floyd's heart disease and drug
use were contributing factors
judge cahill had the final word on
whether the jury would hear from maurice
hall
i had earlier said that possibly he
could talk about
how mr floyd looked in the car but
council's argument is persuasive that
that could provide a link and since it's
not just
evidence that would incriminate a person
but also provide a link to incriminating
evidence
i do find that his invocation of his
fifth amendment rights is valid
now judge cahill based on all of that
ended up quashing the subpoena from
maurice hall meaning he basically made
it go away
hall is currently free on bail and will
be back in court in hennepin county
in june brian thanks antoinette and when
the jury was finally brought in they
heard from a forensic pathologist
hired by the defense who provided a set
of findings that sharply contradicted
everything that's been heard before
about the cause of george floyd's death
so in my opinion mr floyd had a
sudden cardiac arrhythmia or cardiac
arrhythmia
due to his atherosclerotic and
hypertensive
heart disease during his restraint and
subdued by the police or restrained by
the police
and then his significant contributory
conditions
would be since i've already put the
heart disease in part
one he would have
the toxicology the fentanyl and
methamphetamine
exposure to a vehicle exhaust
so potentially carbon monoxide poisoning
or at least
an effect from increased carbon monoxide
in his bloodstream
and paragonglianoma or the other
natural disease process that he has so
all of those combined to
cause mr floyd's death terry austin most
of dr foyle's testimony contradicted
pretty sharply the medical experts thus
far
what was your opinion about his
testability especially on carbon
monoxide
brian i have to wonder why eric nelson
is
raising the issue of carbon monoxide i
mean we might as well throw in the
kitchen sink the prosecution
did not raise that issue and he himself
dr
fowler said that he's not suggesting
that floyd
died from carbon monoxide there was no
test for carbon monoxide
and yet they went on and on they talked
about the cdc
they talked about the epa they talked
about the who
why are we talking about these levels of
carbon monoxide when it is not even
an issue i think it's irrelevant and i
think it's confusing
and i don't think he added any value to
the defense
and brian buckmeyer how do you think dr
follow held up on cross-examination by
the prosecution
so the crash has been kind of
interesting i would have thought it
would have been a little bit more
heavy-handed a little bit quicker
but it appears that the
cross-examination is slowly going after
each and every detail
uh by this uh this witness and also
also attacking some of his findings and
where he's getting his findings we're
hearing that he didn't fully research
one or two
issues that came up and also that he's
not a pulmonologist so a lot of what
he's talking about in terms of the lack
of breathing or the lack of oxygen he's
not really an expert in so it really
begs the question
why did you put this witness on the only
thing i can think of is to muddle the
waters
so that everyone is so confused they
just end up trying to compromise
i don't know if that's going to work for
the defense though all right thanks
brian still ahead on law on crime daily
derek chovin's defense team called their
use of force expert to the stand
and was his testimony enough to sway the
jury
plus the officer who shot dante wright
now
charged with his death what that means
for the city of brooklyn center
and the state of minnesota
day two of derrick shulman's defense
case in what has to be called a battle
of the experts
brian buckmeyer is back with us now to
talk about their use of force expert
brian
that's right brian the defense called
veteran police instructor barry broad
who was able to testify and said that
the actions of derek shobin were
justified
i felt that derek chovin was justified
and was acting with objective
reasonableness
following minneapolis police department
policy
and current standards of law enforcement
and his interactions with mr floyd
barry brought as a retired police
officer with nearly 30 years of
experience
he's reviewed more than 140 cases
testifying in 10
including on behalf of the defense of
former chicago police officer
jason van dijk in the shooting death of
laquan mcdonnell
broad used a tape measure to show 13
feet between him
and van dyke's attorney and then rush
the attorney and i'll show you
how much time you would have to react to
me
broad says he reached out to the city of
minneapolis when he first saw the video
of george floyd's death
you were ultimately not retained by the
city attorney's office or
the state correct that's correct you
then were
retained by my office yes broad says
he's reviewed videos
witness statements and use of force
policy so it's easy to sit and judge in
an office
on an officer's conduct broad gave his
opinion on what he called
chauvin's first use of force when he
joined officers king
and lane to try to get floyd into the
back of the police vehicle
i felt that that level of resistance
exhibited by mr floyd
justified the officers and higher levels
use of force
that they chose not to select did the
use of force then
continue after mr floyd was
restrained on the ground i don't
consider a prone control
as a use of force broad says the
officers were objectively reasonable
in bringing floyd to the ground if the
officer was justified in using the prone
control
and now the suspect is on the ground in
a prone control
the maintaining of the prone control to
me is not a use of force
why is it not a use of force because
it's a control technique without it
doesn't hurt
you've put the suspect in a position
where it's safe for you the officer
say for them the suspect and broad says
the growing crowd size became an
additional threat
to the officers i could see that officer
chauvin's
focus started to move from mr floyd to
the crowd
to one point i think officer chauvin
felt threatened enough that he withdrew
his pepper spray canister
and gave rubble commands to the crowd to
stay back
so now he's dealing with the bigger
threat prosecutor steve slesher
then cross-examined broad for more than
an hour and a half
if you believe that it is unlikely
that orienting yourself on top
of a person on the pavement with both
legs
is unlikely to produce pain it could
what do you mean it could is it unlikely
to produce pain or is it likely to
produce pain
i'm saying it could it's at any time do
you recall
noting mr floyd saying my neck hurts i
heard it i didn't necessarily note it
because your testimony was premised on
this not being a use of force
because there was no pain involved right
yes but you didn't note that
in fact slasher played the body cam
video stopping to analyze
each portion of it what part of this is
not compliant
so i see his arm position compliant
person would have both their hands in
the small their back and just be resting
comfortably versus like he's still
moving around
did you say resting comfortably or
laying comfortably
resting comfortably on the pavement yes
at this point in time
when he's attempting to breathe by
shoving his shoulder into the pavement
i was describing what the signs of a
perfectly compliant person would be
mr floyd doesn't appear to be conscious
at the end of this clip does he
i can't tell he's not resisting he's not
talking it's not possible is it
to do what resist i think it's
definitely possible it resists when you
passed out
he's not doing it here is he not when
he's passed out no
brian the pool report suggested some
jurors were actually nodding off during
the defense case are
eric nelson's uh experts making any
inroads
i don't think so especially in this line
of cross-examination brian let me put it
this way
i get it i'm a public defender i do what
eric nelson does as well but before i
put an argument out there i make sure it
passes what i call the laugh test
i asked my mother my father my friends
i've asked terry i've asked you
does this make sense is this something
that a jury is going to
not only understand but also a credit if
i say
i don't think eric nelson ran this line
of questioning through the laugh test
and i think he's should be happy that
they're falling asleep and not laughing
at him as they're asking questions like
oh
compliance is laying there with your
hands resting on the small of your back
i don't think it passed a laptop i don't
think it made sense and terry austin the
use of force expert barry broad talked a
lot about what constitutes use of force
in the broader context
do you think he was familiar with the
minneapolis police department definition
of use of force
obviously not i don't think so brian
because he was saying that
using prone control did not constitute
use of force because it didn't inflict
pain but we know for a fact that that's
contrary to minneapolis police policy
which
definitely says that this type of
restraint does
constitute use of force and you heard
there on the clip
that if it's on the concrete that if
he's in handcuffs
if there's manipulation of the hands
that
in fact all of that could cause pain so
ultimately
he did admit that all of this together
could be use of force
so i don't think he was very effective
for the defense i think the prosecution
did a great job
in making sure that what happened to
george floyd
was use of force all right thanks terry
coming up on law on crime daily
what led to the arrest of two men in the
murder two decades ago
of college student kristin smart plus
the death of 20 year old dante wright
the officer who shot him
has now been arrested what's next in the
[Music]
investigation
next a major development in the shooting
death of a young man just miles up the
road from the derrick chauvin trial
law and crimes kim johnson is here with
the latest in the dante rice case
kim yeah brian
kim potter the former brooklyn center
police officer accused of shooting and
killing 20-year-old dante
wright has been arrested and charged
with second-degree
manslaughter that is a charge that
carries up to
10 years in prison now the bureau of
criminal apprehension is handling the
investigation
and booked the 26-year police veteran
into the hennepin county
jail on tuesday she resigned from the
police department along with police
chief
tim gannon who called sunday's shooting
during a traffic stop
an accident when potter mistook her gun
for a taser now attorney ben crump has
been retained
by the wright family and in a statement
he said that while
we appreciate the district attorney
pursuing justice for
dante no conviction gives the right
family
or their loved one back and he goes on
to call the shooting
intentional and deliberate and said
that potter should have known the
difference between a taser
and a firearm brian all right kim the
prosecution in this case seems to move
very quickly without even going to a
grand jury before bringing charges
yeah in fact this entire case has moved
quickly if you think about it it was
sunday that the shooting took place in
the afternoon by tuesday
the officer and police chief resigned
and the city manager had been fired and
a day later charges an arrest had been
brought
again though the family have been
calling for this case to move
quickly the community wanting justice
all right thanks kim kim johnson in
minneapolis when we come back
two arrests made in the decades-old
disappearance of college student
kristin smart the new leads in her case
next
[Music]
two men have been arrested in connection
with the 1996 disappearance
and suspected murder of kristen smart
smart was a 19-year-old student at cal
poly state university
when she vanished more than 20 years ago
investigators say they always suspected
ex-classmate
paul flores who walked smart home from a
party when she was last seen
new evidence surfaced in 2016 that
police say
links flores to her murder in 2019 her
case was spotlighted by the podcast
your own backyard investigators then
interviewed several witnesses for the
first time
the san luis obispo sheriff says they
were able to search flores the cell
phone
and homes of his family members
in february of 2020 detectives served
search warrants at the home of paul
flores
as well as his sister mother and father
all
simultaneously last year physical
evidence recovered during these searches
led to the service of additional search
warrant at paul flores residence in
april of last year
during the search warrant detectives
recovered evidence related to
the murder of kristin smart in march of
this year
detectives served another search warrant
in
arroyo grande at the home of reuben
flores
the father of paul flores additional
evidence related to the smart invest
investigation was discovered that
at that time so as a result of
this evidence a san luis obispo spirit
court judge
signed two arrest warrants and two
additional search warrants
paul flores has now been arrested and is
charged with murder
his father reuben flores was also
arrested and is charged with
accessory to murder smart's body has not
yet been recovered
but the sheriff says he's hopeful
we're after all kinds of things physical
evidence again
anything anything that might lead us to
the location of kristin
um and as you know from the previous
search and as you reported from this
search
we're out there with you know our ground
penetrating radar
again so yes it's it's safe to say we're
we're checking everywhere possible
forensic physical evidence was located
and yes we believe it's it's linked to
kristin
and yes we did find physical evidence
at at least two homes
so brian buckmeyer a very cold case but
they never dropped it over 24 years
yeah this is one of those cases where
we're seeing brian the determination of
the police force
and not giving up just because some
leads may be cold
or because there is not enough evidence
now my curiosity is going to be
what is this evidence that led them to
an arrest after 20 years
i think that's what's on everyone's mind
and what everyone's thinking of
especially
the defense attorney who's going to be
hired for this case you better believe
that argument of well this case went
cold for 20 years
is going to be brought up in that
person's defense without a doubt ontario
the authorities as brian said have found
additional physical evidence
but they still have not located a body
so how difficult to convict someone
without the body of the victim you know
brian it's difficult but it has been
done the prosecution is going to have to
rely
on circumstantial evidence and it has
been said that
it's sort of like running a 100 meter
race and
giving the other side a 40 meter start
so that it's very difficult to catch
up but here we heard that there was some
forensic evidence and what i'm thinking
is perhaps there were remnants
of blood perhaps there was digital
evidence perhaps they have witnesses
and maybe they've done electronic
searches so perhaps they can put
all of that together and it did sound
like they
hope that eventually they will even find
the body
but without the body they can still
proceed forward and they could possibly
get a conviction and you know what else
brian we know it's been done
in the past it was done with jeffrey
dahmer and
we know the durst case is going forward
even without a body
and or could go forward as far as his
ex-wife is concerned so it's been done
and it looks like it will be done in the
future again
and brian certainly the advances in dna
science are important here
yeah dna is going to be a huge part of
this case because they're like you said
there is no body recovered
so you've got to at least make this case
a strong circumstantial evidence case
and dna is going to be that of course
dna doesn't prove that someone handled
something specifically
or that they were they use that object
or were there but it does create that
circumstantial evidence because their
dna was found
there and make a strong case for the
prosecution all right brian and terry
thank you so much and thanks to all of
you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you